zufahrt zum neuen hauptstadt airport
berlin brandenburg menschenleer eine
geisterstadt
eröffnungs termine wurden bekannt
gegeben und wieder verschoben
krisensitzung der flughafenchef soll
sagen wie lange noch gebaut wird und
wann es endlich mit dem flugverkehr los
geht ihnen das auch ganz offen was ich
da immer wieder so im täglichen leben
auf dem flughafen erleben es ist immer
voller überraschung und jeden tag
passiert irgendwas anders und es wäre
das erste mal dass alles genau nach
planung glatt läuft also wir können
damit ausgehen dass ich das noch mal
intern so ein bisschen verschiebt und zu
rütteln und die gefahr eben einer
weiteren verschiebung nach hinten die es
gegeben
am neuen berliner flughafen treibt eine
pannenserie die baukosten in die höhe
experten gehen von etwa fünf milliarden
euro aus das hauptproblem bleibt die
brandschutzanlage die ist nicht
funktionsfähig und damit bleibt der
flughafen zu mitten auf dem
flughafengelände sind aber schon einige
mieter eingezogen zum beispiel diese
zahnärzte
natürlich habe nie gewusst dass die
verschiebung über jahre geht die erste
die über ein halbes jahr sich gezogen
hätte fangen wir toll weil wir ab so den
stress waren bei der zweiten habe mir
schon überlegt ob es eine dritte oder
eine vierte geben wird haben dann aber
gesagt egal jetzt machen wir das und
müssen jetzt mit der konsequenz unserer
entscheidung leben und der klasse sagt
ja das ist das netteste was ich bis
jetzt gehört habe womit rechnen sie
mittlerweile mit
wir rechnen mit dem schlimmsten und sind
damit eigentlich bis jetzt immer sehr
gut gefahren
mehr als 600.000 euro haben sie in ihre
flughafen praxis investiert
bisher rechneten sich aber nur zwei
ihrer vier behandlungsräume
zu tag mehr licht also können wir mehr
mitarbeiter und man wundert sich immer
woher sie alle kommen sind sehr viel es
ist ja ein sehr großes gelände darf man
nicht vergessen ich also sind ja auch
alle wichtigen gewerke hier vor ort
schon nicht mehr so feuerwehr die müssen
ja auch da sein der zoll das schon da
ich genau die werner buss entsprechend
dann hochgefahren
wenn dann lebt betrieb am flughafen dann
tatsächlich losgeht die erfahrungen mit
großprojekten hat dieser unabhängige
bauexperte die ständigen
terminverschiebungen am flughafen aus
seiner sicht ein unding sind die
unternehmer die darin investiert haben
und jetzt darauf warten dass da was
passiert was nicht passiert das ist auch
dem gegenüber für ganz besonders
verwerflich dass man hier letztendlich
politische spielchen spielt die laufen
ja nach wie vor wenn sie das ganz genau
verfolgen und das wohl des
steuerzahlenden bürger völlig außer acht
lässt jeder monat verzögerung kostet
millionen euro die öffentlichkeit will
sich nicht länger vom flughafen chef
hinhalten lassen
doch der gibt sich unbeeindruckt sie mir
in eigener sache zu sagen ich bin zum
flughafen geholt wurden um mich fertig
zu machen meine rolle ist da den treiber
zu spielen nach vorne zu pushen und und
das rangiert auch unter der überschrift
was fertig gemacht werden kann wird
fertig gemacht und das so schnell wie
möglich am ende des tages bleiben
explodierende kosten in milliardenhöhe
und die eröffnung ist weiterhin nicht in
sicht